so fox's alert now 19 past the hour
getting rare insight into the early days
of the pandemic now after newly released
emails
linked to dr anthony fauci among the
many revelations his correspondence were
the key figure linked to the wuhan lab
reports showing that a lead researcher
personally thanked falchi
for downplaying the covid lab league
theory early on this is
april of last year now this comes as
many major news outlets are now
acknowledging they originally dismissed
that possibility
david asher is a senior fellow hudson
institute part of the state department
inquiry
into the origins of covet that president
biden shut down earlier this year david
welcome back to our program and
good morning to you going to read this
line he's
uh david um peter dazak is his name
uh he's from britain he sent this email
in april of last year
i just wanted to say a personal thank
you on behalf of our staff and
collaborators for publicly standing up
and stating that
the scientific evidence supports a
natural for covenant 19 from a bat to
human spillover
not a lab release from the wu honey
institute of virology
from my perspective your comments are
brave and coming from your trusted voice
it will help dispel the myth being spun
around the viruses
origin to which faucia responded thank
you for your kind
note so
fauci dismissed this early on and pretty
much
said so publicly how do we look back on
that now
13 months later he was right to dismiss
it because
daisy seems to be working for some other
power
in some bizarre way i can't figure it
out i don't know if any proof of it but
i mean he was tweeting on december 31st
of 2019
that this is coming out of a lab or
something to that effect
um you know he's a guy who's a
epidemiologist who loves epidemics and
you know i i i guess we shouldn't blame
him
somebody needs to care about these
things they're serious but
this was a this is a case of where we
probably had a
epidemic that was you know most likely
caused
by human gain of function not by nature
and he needs to be uh looked at
carefully by the u.s government okay so
to to be clear here
foucher's response is quote it's totally
consistent with the jump of the species
from an aminal to a human
a lot of other people said it's too
early to make that conclusion but that
was his response dayzak blames fox news
because a reporter have the gall to ask
president trump at the time
about a theory about an intern who
worked at the lab and wuhan
who may have leaked that um to the
outside world what do you think of that
david god bless fox news for karen at
the time
um i mean you know we've only lost you
know seven or eight million people in
the world or something according to the
economist maybe 12.
uh you know this is a situation that
that that
defies gravity it's truly like a
salvador dali painting where the clocks
have melted and time has not sit still
if you think about it i mean the
scientists
have come out and said with definitive
authenticity in their voice that they
know where it came from but there's no
proof i mean what i
saw in the government i said give me
your file with nih i went to
cdc i said okay let's have your file i
want the proof
they didn't have a file they didn't i
mean you know i went to
other intelligence agencies and they had
a file i mean
they said well we have suspicions that
came out of a lab this is why
um you know we need to get to the bottom
of this thing now
and i think president biden is on the
right track because he's given 90-day
suspense to do something
uh and look into this thing but did this
is this is taking way too long can you
imagine how many months has passed
and we still don't know what happened
also daisy
admitted during that 60 minutes
interview that they took the chinese for
their word for it i'm
i'm wondering why you know that the
chinese
why would you do just one more point
we've been told in the last three days
that lab leaks happen all the time
but we we've had epidemiologists on the
air for 15 months
that was not something we heard a lot
and suddenly in the last four days
everybody's talking about it i can
understand that lab leaks happen
but why dismiss it so early on last
comment david
unless he was prompted by somebody else
to dismiss it i mean who knows
what i mean i i've i've seen well i mean
i've worked in
intelligence operations for a large part
of my career i mean lots of people are
told to do
certain things and they don't even
necessarily know
they're not not actually paid who knows
what this guy's motivations are i mean
he was sending
notes to fauci in mid-january so was a
guy named christian anderson from
scripps institute who's very famous who
wrote the letter for
nature saying it couldn't have come out
of nature and we found on february 1st
yesterday that he wrote a letter to
fauci
a note to fauci that said that this
thing was lab altered and it was
genetically engineered
so can you trust these scientists i
don't trust these scientists right now i
trust our national lab scientists
i trust our army scientists i don't
trust these
paid in the pocket by chinese scientists
i'm sorry bill feels like we're the very
beginning of this david we will speak
again soon david asher thanks for coming
in today
nice nice to see you again take care